and the new year's resolutions uh last
thing i'll say um off mike and on mike
and afterwards we also
uh hung out together for new year's
i think from the company perspective
just overall first of all there's an
excitement
for the future
and uh like he tweeted today i think
let's make this the roaring 20s
i think uh
there's an optimism that coming out of
pandemic
will build our way out of it
we will innovate our way out of it
and that means both the software and the
hardware
it's again the [ __ ] that will get it
done
and uh that's
i don't know that that optimism about
the new years uh definitely just
permeates everything so on neurolink i
mean there's a there's a lot of really
ambitious goals so on the neural net
side it's uh
implanting it to humans pending fda
approval all that kind of stuff their
full steam ahead there um
tesla autopilot like you said in the
podcast uh solving level four full self
driving
uh this year
i think you said like um like likely
this year 2022.
of course i could talk for a long time i
probably will about
each
words in that sentence like what is
level four exactly what does solve
exactly mean and uh
what are the sort of the stages of
solution because one is the
the technological two is the deployment
and the human interactions the human
factor side of it three is the policy
like is this going to get approved like
is nets are going to freak out all those
kinds of things and then social
acceptance of the technology all that
you know in interaction with vehicles
that don't have autopilot other tesla
vehicles and then other vehicles in
general so solve
is almost like uh
like wittgenstein would lose his [ __ ]
over the word solve like you know what
does it exactly mean and what does level
four mean is it under certain geographic
locations and so on but
the big point
is that in 2022 there's going to be big
leaps of improvement and that is that is
why the way i hear that message and
their full steam ahead there is so much
exciting stuff going on uh most of it
which is already made public and i don't
know i'm really excited as an ai person
and of course as a person um
you know who grew up in the soviet union
well he shut up about the soviet union
already i'm sorry
i loved my dad as a physicist i i loved
space exploration and to me starship and
just the number of launches that have
planned for 2022 on the spacex side uh
nasa and and everybody else is just like
pushing straight ahead into space uh
hopefully putting a human back on the
moon and hopefully soon enough uh let me
take that 20-second pause as well uh
putting a human on mars maybe this
decade i mean to me that
that's exciting i'll go i'll be the
first human
that's why i'm training with david
goggins to be the first human on mars
you